اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
ساعه اخباريه نناقش في معظمها الاوضاع في
السودان نبدا باهم عناوينها
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه استقبلوا مبعوث
البرهان ويؤكد ضروره وقف كل اشكال التصعيد
العسكري
المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
يحذر من انتشار المواجهات العرقيه مع
استمرار الاشتباكات
نقابه اطباء السودان تحذر من انهيار وشيك
للنظام الصحي بسبب شح الادويه والمستلزمات
الطبيه
وفي هذه الساعه الاخباريه ايضا
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي يقول بانه واثق
من التوصل الى اتفاق بشان خطه الاصلاح
القضائي
[موسيقى]
استقبل وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل ابن فرحان المبعوث الخاص لرئيسي مجلس
السياده الانتقالي السوداني السفير دفع
الله الحاج علي وجرى خلال اللقاء بحث
الاوضاع الراهنه في السودان وقد اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي على دعوه الرياض للتهديه
وتغليب المصلحه الوطنيه ووقف كافه اشكال
التصعيد العسكري بما يحافظ على مقدرات
ومكتسبات السوداني وشعبه
اما ميدانيا ومع دخول المعارك بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها الثالث تجددت
الاشتباكات حيث شهدت منطقه المهندسين
والصالحه مواجهات بالاسلحه الخفيفه
والثقيله وقصفا بالطيران بحسب مراسل
العربيه وقد افاد شهود عيان من الحلفايه
شمال مدينه الخرطوم بحري ببدء الجيش في
نشر وحداته والقيام بعمليات تمشيط بعد
معارك عنيفه شهدتها المنطقه هذا وتجدد
سماع دوي انفجارات واصوات اطلاق نار في
محيط القياده العامه للجيش
الان
ضخمه جدا
وضخمه جدا
من الجيش
نشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل اسفل الشاشه
متحدث الجيش السوداني للعربيه نقوم
بعمليات تمشيط واسعه في بحر وجنوب ام
درمان كذلك كان الجيش السوداني قد قال
بانه يجري عمليات تنشيط بالقرب من جسر
حلفايه متحدث الجيش السوداني ايضا يقول
بان الجيش السوداني يهدف الى طرد قوات
الدعم السريع من المناطق السكنيه اذا
متحدث الجيش السوداني يقول العربيه بانهم
يقومون بعمليات تمشيط واسعه في بحر وجنوب
ام درمان وايضا ربما شاهدنا اليوم الجيش
السوداني وهو يقوم كذلك
بعمليات تمشيط واسعه في جسر حلفايه متحدث
الجيش السوداني اضاف ايضا للعربيه بانهم
يهدفون الى طرد قوات الدعم السريع من
المناطق السكنيه يضيف ايضا الى جمله هذه
التصريحات
ان الموقف العملياتي مستقر تماما كل هذه
التصاريح على لسان متحدث الجيش
السوداني للعربيه سنوافيكم بمزيد طبعا من
المعلومات والاخبار حلمه جده جديد من
تصريحات للجيش السوداني او لقوات الدعم
السريعه للجانب الاخر اذا الخرطوم العاصمه
شهدت قارات جويه واطلاق نار متبادل بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع مع دخول المعارك
اسبوع الثالث
السودان اسبوع ثالث من القتال
مخاوف من ان يؤدي الصراع الى حرب طويله
الامد
صراع انفجر منتصف ابريل ولم يهدا بعد
طرف صراعي الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع
قرران مواجهه بالسلاح وتبادل الاتهامات
اعلاميا
حصيله كبيره من القتلى والجرحى
الاف الفرينه الى دول الجوار وعمليات
اجلاء كبيره ومستمره
واستظروف انسانيه صعبه
هدنه معلنه وجهود دوليه لوقف القتال
لكن اعمده الدخان لم تغب عن سماء الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم السريع بمواصله
انتهاك الهدنه المعلنه من خلال عمليات
تحشيد تقوم بها غرب العاصمه الخرطوم الجيش
دان استمرار القصف العشوائي وعمليات نهب
الممتلكات بما فيها البنوك ومنازل
المواطنين وقال بيان للجيش ان قوات الدعم
السريع حولت مستشفى شرق النيل الى تكنه
ومركز قياده لعملياتها البيان اكد استمرار
الجيش في تهيئه الظروف المناسبه لنزول
الشرطه تدريجيا الى الشوارع
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت هي الاخرى الجيش
بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من مناطق
الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائرات بيان الدعم
السريع اشاره الى ان الطائرات الجيش ما
تزال تحلق في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم وتنتهك
الهدنه الدعم السريع قال ان الجيش يستعد
لشن هجوم في العاصمه الخرطوم ومدينه
الحلفايه وام درمان وبحري
ومن دنفر عاصمه ولايه كولورادو الامريكيه
ينضم الينا خبير الشؤون الافريقيه ابراهيم
ادريس سيد ابراهيم مرحبا بك معي في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه على شاشه العربيه ابدا
معك اولا من مالات الحل السياسي كانت هناك
دعوه ولقاء ايضا بين وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع مبعوث
ايضا مجلس السياده السوداني في المملكه
برايك الى ماذا ترمي هذه الزياره ما الذي
يمكن ان ينتج عنها ايضا
بلادنا الشك دور السعوديه الان سيكون في
مقدمه وطليعه فتح المنافذ الاولى
لهذه المبادرات التي
خلفها الاتحاد الافريقي والمجتمع الدولي
بكل مؤسساته
وجود السيد السفير دفع الله الحاج في قمه
هذا الوفد وهو شخصيه معروفه بانه كان مدير
عام للقضايا الدوليه في وزاره الخارجيه
السودانيه وكما كان ايضا المندوب الدائم
للسودان من 2010 على ما اعتقد على 2013
هذا يكشف انه السفير دفع الله هو يعني
مبعوث لرئيس مجلس السياده وهذا يعني بادره
اثبتت انه الدوله السودانيه بدات الان
تظهر ليس في ثوبها العسكري لكن في ثوبها
الدبلوماسي والسيادي كونها ترسل وفد ده
معناها
لوجستيكيه تحول جديد يبشر
بتداعيات ايجابيه وجود وجوده الان في
السعوديه وفي يعني مقابله السيد فيصل بني
سرحان ولا منه
السيده الوزير كان له علاقات مباشره مع كل
المؤسسات الدوليه وتحديدا الخارجيه
المصريه والخارجيه الامريكيه وهذا يعني
انه قاب قوسين وادنى سنرى انفراج في هذه
المفاوضات التي
لم نبشر لها خيرا فيما يخص لقاء الطرفين
هل حان وقت الحلول الدبلوماسيه برايك
السيد ابراهيم ام لازال هناك ما يحتاج
يعني الى حسمه عسكريا في الارض اولا وبعد
ذلك الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات
اذكرك بانه واقع تاريخيه لكن مهمه ذكرها
الان رغم انها بعيده المدى فيتنام عندما
كانت التفاوض مع امريكا اهم
نقطه فاتت على انهم الفيتنامين طولوا هذا
الحوار الى ان يستتب الوضع العسكري ويكون
لهم الغلبه الان يبدو المراحل العسكريه
التي توصلت لها
[موسيقى]
جيش السوداني
بادواته وادخاله
لطاقم الضخم من الامس من البوليس وقوات
مهمه جدا
تعني بشان حمايه المدن وحمايه المدن
اذكرها لانه حرب الشوارع الان قام قوسين
ادنى ان تكون محاصره لا سيما انه قوات
الدعم السريع بدات تفقد توازنها
ومصادر دعمها اللوجستيكيه هذا ينبئ بانه
هناك خطوات ايجابيه توصل لها
السيد البرهان وقياده العسكريه وتحديدا
لكن هذا من جانب السيد البرهان والجيش
السوداني لكن على على الطرف الاخر المقابل
قوات الدعم السريع الجنرال حماتي ايضا هل
يمكن ان يدخلوا في عمليه تفاوض او حتى
افاد احد من قيادات الدعم السريع في ظل
هكذا وضع ميداني كما وصفته انت كما وصفه
الجيش ايضا السوداني بان الدعم السريع فقد
القدره على مهاجمه اي موقع عسكري وبان
الموقف العملياتي مستقر تماما كما ذكر
متحدث الجيش السوداني
هذه هي الانباء التي وصلت لكن عطفا على
سؤالك
حميتي بالامس ارسل رسائل متعدده وحدد
علاقات
ومرمى لتواصل مع الدوله الامريكيه
والسعوديه وايضا طرح قضيه تبنيه
للديمقراطيه والدوله المدنيه بتفاصيل اكثر
جاذبيه للمستمع في المجتمع الدولي هل هذا
هو حقيقه وموقفه وهل هو عنده الامكانيه
الان لانه يعني يرسل وفد هذه القضايا التي
لم تجاوب عليها المعلومات التي توفد لنا
من الخرطوم وحتى من المراقبون طيب تعال
نتحدث ايضا كذلك عن وساطه الايجاد
برايك سيد ابراهيم هل هذه الوساطه وهذه
المبادره تستوعب المشهد السوداني اليوم
بكل يعني بكل ما فيه هل تستوعب طرفي هذه
الازمه ام هناك ما ينقص هذه المبادره
برايك
المبادره ينقصها الان الجزء الاهم
الجزء الاهم عندما اقول ليس هناك موقف
ايجابي في هذه المرحله وفي هذه الصراعات
الداميه والسياسيه الطاحنه غير الايطاليه
الاطاريه لم نسمع عنها شيء لم نسمع منها
هي ايضا متابعات واضحه لمجريات المقالات
ما بعد الايقاف الحرب هنا هذا الفراق قد
يكون سيطرح في الاجتماع او قد نتوقع من
الاتحاد الافريقي اذا وصل وفده الى
الخرطوم برئاسه سلفاكير وعضويه
دوله جيبوتي وكينيا هناك سنسمع هذا الطرف
الغائب لكن الان تم حصار هذه
المبادرات في طرفي الصراع العسكري الجانب
السياسي والجانب الاهم والجانب المستقبلي
للتحول المدني والوصول الى
السلامه الدائم في السودان هذه القضيه
ارى انها لم تناقش بجديه ولم تاتي اللحظه
المناسبه لانه نسمع من الاطراف المعنيه من
الدول الرباعيه والسداسيه والاتحاد
الافريقي والمجتمع الدولي بكل قواه بما
فيهم السعوديه التي تلعب دور اساسي والتي
لعبته سابقا من خلال الثلاثيه عن طريق
سفيرها في الخرطوم كل هذه المعطيات تشير
بان هناك فراغ
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من ذم فرع عاصمه ولايه
كولورادو الامريكيه خبير الشؤون الافريقيه
ابراهيم ادريس شكرا لك
شاهد حي جبرا جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم اسواق
اشتباكات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع نتابع
[موسيقى]
تفاقم الاوضاع الطبيه انعكس على قطاع
الادويه حيث ازدادت ازمه نقص الادويه في
الخرطوم مع استمرار المواجهات المسلحه
وحضر تجمع الصياديلا المهنيين بالسودان من
كارثه صحيه بسبب عمليات نهب الصيدليات
وشركات ومخازن الادويه في مدن العاصمه
الثلاث بالتزامن مع اغلاق عدد كبير من
الصيدليات في ام درمان
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك في ادويه
الضغط وادويه السكري
والادويه بتشتغل على الجهاز العصبي او
الادويه التعسير العصبي
خصوصا مرضى الصرع
طبعا اساسا عندهم مشكله في الحي الادويه
دي اساسا ما متوفره في الظروف العاديه
فيها شح والان المشكله بقت اكبر بالاضافه
للفوط الصحيه
للسيدات تكاد تكون الان ما موجوده خالص
كمان مشكله الالبان عند الاطفال دي مشكله
كارثه حقيقيه الان الالبان غير موجوده
وجدت الاحداث الدواء حقي كمل انسانين
مخلوط ومعاه الحقن او لذاته
ما خلينا حتى ما لقينا
ومعنا من ام درمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه
في السودان شادي نادر شادي مرحبا بك معي
في هذه الساعه اريد ان ابدا اولا من
الاوضاع الميدانيه في ام درمان الجيش
السوداني يقول بانه يقوم بعمليات تمشيط
واسعه في اندرمان انقل لنا الصوره من حولك
ما يجري هو في جنوب ام درمان وكذلك منطقه
شرطا ام درمان لو كنت تسمع في مطايره
حربيه الان تحلق في سماء المدينه اصوات
المضادات التي عاودت قبل حوالي ساعه
مسموعه هي الان لو كنت لو كنت لو كانت
الكاميرا تلتقط هذه هذه الاصوات ولكن
اليوم ميدانيا على مستوى
الافضل
نعم اليوم الوضع افضل بكثير خرجت هناك في
المتحركه اليوم ملحوظه لم تكن
اخو
اننا فتحت ابوابها بشكل كلي اليوم
ازدحام من المواطنين
شادي طيب يبدو اننا
لو كنت تشاهد الشارع
لازم معك شهري الصوره انقطعت فقط تفضل
شاهدي هل تسمعني الان هي ان كما تشاهد
اصطفاف نعم نعم اسمعوا تفضل تفضل اكمل
لو كنت تشاهد اليوم
السيارات امام محطات الوقود بعضها ما يزال
خارج الخدمه وبعضها بدا في العمل بشكل
تدريجي اليوم الحركه هنا مسافه بشكل كبير
للمواصلات العامه عاودت هي باسعار مرتفعه
الى
حد مضاعفه نسبه لشحن الوقود ولكن
مجملا اليوم هو يكاد يكون اليوم الافضل
على المنطقه هنا طوال ايام هذه هذه الهدنه
او منذ بدايه اعلان وفي اطلاق النار ما
بين الجانبين طيب متى توفر المعينات
الاساسيه يعني في هذه المحال التجاريه
التي فتحت ابوابها بعد مده من اغلاقها
شهدي
الذي يطلق عليها البقالات غالبيتها
توقفت او على وشك ان تتوقف لجهه عدم قدره
سيارات نقل البضائع من المصانع والمخازن
اليها ولكن المحاله الكبيره التي لديها
مقدور ربما يكفي
ايام
قادمات
تتمكن من تلبيه حاجيات المواطنين عده ايام
ولكن ان لم تتمكن سيارات نقل البطايق من
مصانعه من مخازنها وانت تاتي بها الى
الاسواق ومحاشيات
تكون
هناك ندره في بعض
السلع مشاكل في الايام القادمه طيب انت
تتحدث عن ارتفاع في الاسعار شاهدي فيما
يخص الوقود المواد الغذائيه ايضا وحتى
ربما ندره في الادويه كما شاهدنا في
التقرير قبل قليل كيف انعكس ذلك على
الاسعار عندما نقارنها قبل هذه الازمه
واليوم
نعم المحل تمسكت بي ان تبيع فيها الاسعار
القديمه عدم الغاء اضافه على مواطنين
خارجين من شهر رمضان
والعقيد واستعدادات التي كانت تجري اخواني
هذه الاحتياجات البعض الاخر يتحصل على
بضائع ولكن باسعار مرتفعه نسبه لارتفاع
كلفه الله الترحيل انت تعلم بان اسعار
اللتر الوقود تضاعفت بشكل مبالغ فيه يعني
اذا كان اللتر الجالون البنزين يباع في
المحطه بالسعر الرسمي لا تجاوز الثلاثه
الاف جنيه ولكن اليوم
وهذا مبلغ كبير جدا بعض هؤلاء وجد نفسه
مضطر ليحصل على
الدقيق للخبز وبعض اصحاب المخابز لجاوا
السوق للحصول على ما يحتاجون هذا القعيد
اضافي على عمليه على اسعار المنتجات
الاستهلاكيه بشكل
بدات ولكن في محل الكبرى كما قلت لك هي
لديها بعض الذي ربما يكفي لايام قادمات
ولكن لن يستطيع ان
يكفي المؤنث ان يكفي المواطنين لي اذا ما
استمر الحال على ما هو عليه
الشكر من ام درمان الصحفي في مكتب العربيه
في السودان شاهدي نادر شكرا جزيلا
وعلى خلفيه المواجهات المسلحات المستمره
بدا موظفون في ولايه الخرطوم عطله رسميه
حتى اشعار اخر وذلك بسبب الظروف الامنيه
التي تعيشها البلاد ولا تشمل العطله غرف
اداره الازمه والمرافق الخدميه الحيويه
في سياق المتصله اعلنت ولايتها القضارف
ونهر النيل في السودان حاله الطوارئ
لمواجهه تداعيات الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا
في البلاد حيث امر والي القضارف باعلان
حاله الطوارئ لمده شهر مؤكدا ان من يخالف
الاوامر يعرض نفسه للغرامه او السجن هذا
واعلن والي نهر النيل حاله الطوارئ
بالولايه ووجه الجهات المختصه بتنفيذ
الامر وفق وسائل اعلام محليه
اما في ولايه غرب دارفور فقد اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء حصر 94 حاله وفاه جراء الاشتباكات
في مدينه الجنينه قبل ذلك اعلن الجيش
السوداني في بيان له ان لجنه امن الولايه
نجحت بالحد من التوتر القبلي وان شرطه
الاحتياطي تفتح تدريجيا مناطق في جنوب
الخرطوم الجيش السوداني اشار في بيانه الى
ان الموقف العملياتي مستقر في جميع
المناطق العسكريه بالبلاد مؤكدا استمرار
بعض الدول باجلاء راعيها من الخرطوم
وبورتسودان
حاليا نحن في المنطقه بتاعت المرسى
شامباك المواطنين السكان في المنطقه
المجاوره من
مباشره من النيل
شيلوها من النيل ومن هنا من المرسى وانت
ماشي فالناس بتعاني جدعاني شديد جدعاني
تتحرك
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو انتشر عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي لحظه فرار طلاب في جامعه
الخرطوم بعد سماع اطلاق نيران عند احد
المداخل
[تصفيق]
هكذا شرطه السودانيه ان قوات الاحتياطيه
المركزيه فصيل تابع لها وقد تم الدفع به
الى الشوارع لتامين الاسواق وممتلكات
المواطنين وشددت على ان من يقودها هم
خريجوا الشرطه وكليه الشرطه والقانون
وقالت الشرطه ردا على الدعم السريع في
البيان انه لا وجود للامن الشعبي في قوات
الاحتياطيه المركزي مؤكدا بان مقر البنك
المركزي الرئيسي لم يتعرض لاي هجوم وان
الحريق الذي تم الاعلان عنه يعود لاحد
فروع البنك
وفي متابعه للاوضاع الصحيه اعلن تناقبت
الاطباء في السودان ارتفاع عدد القتل
المدنيين جراء الاشتباكات الى
425 شخصا واصابه 2091 شخصا اشارت النقابه
الى ان سته عشر مستشفى تعرض للقصف منذ
بدايه المواجهات حيث طالت عمليات القصف
مستشفى البراحه في الخرطوم بحري يوم امس
من جانبه حذر عطيه عبد الله سكرتير نقابه
اطباء السودان في تصريحاته للعربيه من ان
انهيار النظام الصحي في او من انهيار
النظام الصحيه في البلاد وقال ان هذا
الانهيار اصبح وشيكا بسبب عدم توفر
الادويه والمستلزمات الطبيه اللازمه
لتقديم العلاج
انهيار النظام الصحي اصبح وشيكا نراه راي
العين
كان في الخدمات الطبيه في المستشفيات نقص
سحاد في المعينات الطبيه
عدم القدره الى الوصول الى المستشفيات من
الكوادر الطبيه او الاسعاف
نقص حاد في اكياس الدم نقص حاد في
معينات غسيل الكلى نقص حاد في الادويه
المنقذه للحياه والادويه المستخدمه في
العمليات الجراحيه النقص في كل مكان
يكاد نكون وصلنا الى المرحله الصفريه في
عدد من المعينات الطبيه الضروريه
نحاول جاهدين ان نعمل على تحويل عدد من
الحالات الحرجه الى
الولايات المجاوره ولكن هي الاخرى اذا حتى
هي مخزونات سوف ينضب
عبد الله قال ايضا للعربيه ان هناك مخاوف
حقيقيه من ان تصل البلاد الى وقت لا
تستطيع فيه الكوادر الطبيه من تاديه
واجباتها بسبب الاقتتال
نحن نتخوف من تاتي لحظه لا يستطيع الكادر
الطبي القيام بواجبه المهني والاخلاقي
نريد كاولويه الان هي وقف هذه الحرب فورا
ومن ثم فتح ممرات امنه للوصول الى
المستشفيات وايضا فتح كل المخازن
الامدادات الطبيه داخل وخارج الخرطوم الى
وتغذيه المستشفيات فتح المجال الجوي
والبري والبحري للمعينات الانسانيه من
الدول الصديقه والمحبه للشعب السوداني
ايضا نحن نطالب بعدم استهداف الكوادر
الطبيه وعدم استهداف المنشات الطبيه
من القاهره ينضم الينا ننطق باسم اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان الدكتور
سيد محمد عبد الله دكتور سيد مرحبا بك معي
على شاشه العربيه بدايه ما الذي توفر
لديكم من معلومات من احصاءات للوضع
السوداني الصحي حتى الساعه
اهلا وسهلا وشكرا لقناه العربيه لاهتمامها
لنعمل سويا مع الخيرين في بلادنا في
العالم لايقاف هذه الحرب وبالتالي ايقاف
معاناه شعبنا كما تفضل زميلي الدكتور عطيه
سكرتير النقابه
فالوضع كارثي في هذه
المستشفيات والمراكز الصحيه
حتى كما تعلمون سبعين بالمئه من هذه
المستشفيات خرج تماما عن الخدمه 61 مستشفى
من جمله 86 مستشفى في منطقه الاشتباكات
توقفت تماما عن العمل وهذه الخمسه وعشرين
مستشفى التي بقيت تعمل بشكل بعضها او
معظمها يعمل بشكل جزئي ويقدم زعافات اوليه
للطوارئ وللاصابات نحن نتحدث على الخرطوم
دكتور 16 مستشفى
نعم المعظمه في الخرطوم كل هذه المستشفيات
معظمها في الخرطوم ما عدا مستشفيات الابيض
واربع قصفت في مدينه الابيض في غرب
السودان وتوقف مستشفى جنينه تماما كما ذكر
زميلي
ونتيجه لذلك حتى هذه المستشفيات المتبقيه
تعمل بشكل جزئي معظمها لانعدام الامدادات
الطبيه ولنقص الكادر الطبي الذي ظل يعمل
في هذه المستشفيات لمده اكثر من اسبوعين
ونسبه
الخطوره التحرك وللقصف
ولصعوبه
الامدادات ولنقص الكهرباء والمياه تعذر
استبدالهم مما جعلهم ابن هكينه تماما
فالوضع كارثي لا يمكن وصفه بانه اكثر من
كارثي فيما يخص الوفيات الجرحى الارقام او
تحديثات لها دكتور سيد
نعم يعني
الى لحد الامس كان بلغ بلغت الوفيات
425 وفاه وسط المدنيين كما تعلمون هذه
التقارير تصلنا فقط من المستشفيات قد يكون
تكون الاعداد اضعاف لان لا تشمل العسكريين
ولا تشمل الذين لم يتمكنوا من الوصول لهذه
المستشفيات والمراكز عدد الاصابات بلغ
2091 وسط المدنيين اؤكد انه وسط المدنيين
كثير من هذه الاصابات لم تستطيع الوصول
لعدم وجود الممرات الامنه ولان عربات
الاسعاف سته منها تم قصفها وحتى
البقيه لم تستطيع المرور لنقلها هؤلاء
الجرحى ونقل الامدادات الطبيه لذلك هذه
الاعداد كما اؤكد انها قد تكون اضعاف
اضعاف هذا العدد الذي ذكرت
اضعاف المعلن كما ذكرت وهناك ايضا حديث عن
تراكم للجثث في الخرطوم وهذا الخطر ايضا
كيف يمكن التعامل معها وصفها وماذا لديكم
من معلومات بشانها ايضا كذلك
للاسف الشديد يعني اللي انتشرت الجثث في
اماكن متفرقه
وهذا يشكل خطر بي ويحتاج لتعامل خاص
لدفنها وللتعامل معها لانها تشكل كارثه
بيئيه وهناك فرق متخصصه ولكن للاسف يعني
لاستمرار الاشتباكات لم يتمكن
العاملين على على ادلائها نعمل ونرجو من
الدفاع المدني
للصليب الاحمر
والهلال الاحمر وكل المنظمات ان تتمكن من
اجلاء هذه الجثث بالطريقه العلميه
والطريقه التي تليق بكرامه الانسان اشكرك
جزيلا شكرا من القاهره الناطق باسم اللجنه
التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السوداني الدكتور
سيد محمد عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك
وفي هذه الاثناء اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه ان اجمالي من تم اجلائهم من
السودان الى جده وصل الى 513 شخصا ينتمون
لمئه دوله واوضحت الخارجيه السعوديه انه
تم اجراء 45 مواطنا سعوديا
وسته وثلاثين شخصا من الجنسيه الباكستانيه
اليوم من السودان الى قاعده الملك عبد
الله الجويه بالقطاع الغربي في جده
واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه ان المملكه وفرت
كافه الاحتياجات الاساسيه لرعايه الدول
الشقيقه والصديقه تمهيدا لتسهيل مغادرتهم
الى اوطانهم
ونتابع هذه الصور المباشره من قاعده الملك
عبد الله الجويه في مدينه جده غرب
السعوديه ومن هناك ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه نصفيان هاني مرحبا بك معنا هل
تستطيع
هاني ان تلخص لنا هذه الصوره هذه الطائره
التي وصلت يبدو لانها لاحدى الجنسيات
الاسيويه الهنديه ربما
[موسيقى]
صحيح صحيح نايف اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين
قناه العربيه مره اخرى نواكب اذن الجسر
الجوي هنا من قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
بالقطاع الغربي ولحظه وصول الان ونزول
تحديدا رعايه الجنسيه الهنديه الذين وصلوا
للتو وعددهم 135 راكب ما بين كبار وصغار
عبر طائره عسكريه هنديه من نوع سي 1 30
والقادمه من بورد سودان طبعا هذه الرحله
وصلت للتو لذلك وبذلك يرتفع عدد الرحلات
التي غادرت ووصلت قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه 48
رحله باعداد تتجاوز ال
4400 راكب طبعا هؤلاء الرعايه هم الان هم
يتوجهون الى
الصاله المخصصه لهم داخل قاعه او داخل
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه ويتم بعدها
المراحل في عمليه
اطمئنان على صحتهم وبعد ذلك انهاء
الاجراءات وكذلك نقلهم عبر الحافلات وهناك
ايضا الممثل الخاص
بالسفاره الهنديه موجود هنا طبعا في هذه
الرحله هناك ايضا اصابتين
اصيبتا في بورت سودان سوف نقوم بالدخول
ونرافق ايضا هذا الفريق الطبي
لتابع للقوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه وهو
فريق مختص في العياده الطبيه سوف يقوم
بنقل الاصابتين طبعا نحن قمنا بالدخول الى
داخل هذه الطائره العسكريه لنوثق الحاله
المصابه وهي بالفعل ليست مصابه ولكنها من
كبار السن لا تستطيع السير ونشاهد ايضا
معظم من هم علامه هذه الطائره هم من كبار
السن من الرعايه الجنسيه الهنديه وايضا
هنا نقوم ايضا باخذ زاويه اخرى
ونشاهد عمليه النقل هذه المسنه طبعا هذه
الطائرات العسكريه تحديدا هي من تقوم او
معظم عمليات الاجلاء تنفذ من خلال الطائره
العسكريه او الطائرات العسكريه للدول
الاجنبيه او كذلك للطائرات العسكريه التي
تقودها القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه
بسبب سرعه عمليات الاجلاء وكذلك من اجل
سلامه وحمايه ايضا الركاب الذين يصعدون او
يتم عمليه اجلائهم كي يتم وصولهم الى
قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه بكل سلامه
وامان وبعد ذلك يتم بدء المراحل الاخرى
طبعا هنا ايضا بجانب الفريق
الطبي هناك ضباط وضباط صف من القوات
الجويه الملكيه السعوديه وكذلك من قبل
الجويه الهنديه الذين يقومون بمساعده
بمساعده الضباط هنا والافراد في القوات
الجويه حتى يتم منحهم نزول هذه السيده او
كذلك الركاب الاخرين الى الى داخل الصاله
بكل يسر وامان وهنا لدينا ايضا احد الضباط
القوات الجويه يقوم بمساعده هذا المسن وهي
من ضمن العمليات الانسانيه التي تقودها
القوات الجويه هنا في قاعده الملك عبد
الله وايضا ضمن
الخطه المعده والتي تنفذها السعوديه من
اجل عمليات الاجلاء للرعايه الجنسيات
المختلفه حتى وصولهم بسلام وامان سوف نقوم
بالدخول الى داخل الصاله قبل
او نرافق ايضا احد الركاب الذي سوف يتجه
الى الصاله الخاصه طبعا لا ننسى ان هناك
قيادات ايضا من القاعده في استقبال هؤلاء
الركاب وهو البروتوكول رسمي يقوم بتقديمه
دائما قائد قائده الملك عبد الله الجويه
او كذلك من يمثله في القاعده
الى جانبه ايضا يقف القنصل
لقنصل الهندي او كذلك ايضا سفراء
وممثلين قنصليات الجنسيات الاخرى وهي من
ضمن ايضا متابعه واشراف لحاله الركاب
وسيرهم حتى وصولهم بسلام هناك المراحل
طبعا كما ذكرت عزيزي نايف انه سوف يقوم
لهؤلاء الركاب منحهم التاشيره الطارئه من
قبل الجوازات السعوديه التي تتواجد في
المواقع التي حددتها السعوديه واحده من
هذه المواقع هي قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه حيث سوف يتم منح هؤلاء الركاب
التاشيره الطارئه حتى تمكنهم من الدخول
الى داخل الاراضي السعوديه وبعد ذلك ايضا
تسهل عليهم عمليه مغادرتهم سواء من خلال
هذه القاعده ام كذا او ايضا من خلال مطار
الملك عبد العزيز الدولي الذي يعتبر واحد
من المنافذ
المحدده
لمغادره الركاب هذه السيده هي جدا سعيده
ومن خلال ابتسامتها وفرحتها نقوم برصدها
ولعل ايضا هي فرحتها واضحه وهي في طريقها
الى الصاله المؤدى طبعا هنا هذه الصاله
كما شاهدنا نشاهدها في اللقطه الاخيره وهي
الصلاه التي معده مخصصه رايه الجنسيه
الهنديه او كذا ذكر رعايه الجنسيات الاخرى
جزيل الشكر على هذه الصوره هذه التفاصيل
التي نقلتها لنا سنتابع معك طبعا في سياق
هذه
النشر ربما او ايضا حتى نشراتنا القادمه
هاني صفين شكرا جزيلا لك انتقل الى ايضا
وفي مشهد كذلك من عمليات الاجلاء مراسل
العربيه نزار البقدوي ينقله لنا نزار
مرحبا بك معي ربما وصلت احدى السفن التي
كنت تتحدث عنها ظهيره هذا اليوم بان هناك
سفن السعوديه امريكيه وبريطانيه ايضا كذلك
ما الذي وصل منها حتى الان
نعم الذي وصل الان قبل قليل هذه القطعه
العسكريه البحريه الضخمه التي تتبع للجيش
الامريكي وصلت قبل قليل الى ميناء
بورسودان هذه القطعه تحركت خلال الساعات
الماضيه في عرضه البحر الاحمر
ووصلت قبل قليل الى هذه النقطه هنا في
الميناء الشمالي تحديدا في نقطه الميناء
الاخضر بمدينه بورسودان هذه القطعه التي
تتبع للبحريه الامريكيه ستعمل على نقل نحو
300 من رعايه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الذين وصلوا يوم الامس الى مدينه بورسودان
والان تجري عمليات النقل الرعايه وبعض ذوي
الحالات او الاحتياجات الخاصه الذين
يحملون الجنسيه الامريكيه كما تشاهدون
الان في هذه الصور الحصريه والخاصه لقناه
العربيه من داخل الميناء الاخضر بمدينه
بورسودان بحضور الجيش السوداني الذي يرتب
هذه العمليه وايضا جنود يتبعون لجيش
الولايات المتحده والبحريه الامريكيه
وهيئه الموانئ البحريه ايضا التي تشرف مع
الجيش السوداني على هذه العمليه يقومون
الان بنقل وترحيل رعايه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من ارضيه الميناء مباشره الى
هذه السفينه الضخمه التي تتبع للبحريه
الامريكيه بمعيه جنود البحريه الامريكيه
الذين وصلوا برفقه هذه القطعه البحريه
الان عمليات الاجلاء تمضي كما تتابعون
الان في الصوره
للسيده يبدو انها مريضه او تعاني بعض
الاضرار
الجسديه الذي يمنعها من ان تنتقل
لوحدها داخل هذه القطعه البحريه هذه نسخه
النسخه الاخرى على شمال مباشره حيث ترابط
سفينه ايضا تتبع الجيش البريطاني هذه
السفينه ايضا رست قبل قليل في ميناء
بورسودان هذه السفينه مزوده بطائره حربيه
الى جانب ايضا وجود للجيش البريطاني الذي
جاء بمعيه هذه القطعه البحريه ستعمل ايضا
كما علمنا على نقل رعايه بريطانيين وعدد
من دول اوروبا وعدد من الدول العربيه
وممثلين لبعثات الدبلوماسيه عمليه الاجلاء
يبدو انها تمضي على اشدها تمضي وفق
الترتيب الموضوع من قبل الجيش ومن قبل
البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي تنسق مع لجنتين
هنا في ولايه البحر الاحمر لجنه معنيه
باجلاء رعايه دول وممثلي البعثات وموظفي
الامم المتحده عبر البحر ولجنه اخرى تنسق
ايضا اجلاء الرعايه عبر مطار بورسودان
الذي
غادرت منه خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر من
ست رحلات بواقع 7000 غادروا خلال الايام
الماضيه عبر الميناء واكثر من تسعه الاف
وخمسمئه من رعايه دول الاجنبيه غادروا عبر
الميناء ميناء بورسودان خلال الساعات
الماضيه هذه العمليه تمضي ونحن في متابعه
مستمره لهذه
التداعيات تداعيات الاشتباكات والمواجهات
المسلحه التي افضت الى هذه المشاهد وهذه
الصور لاكبر عمليه ايلاف السودان هل كل
الرعايه الامريكيين او حتى
البريطانيين او حتى الاوروبيين نزار كلهم
موجودين
بورتسودان ام ان هناك يعني من ينتظر وصوله
الى بورتسودان لكي يصحب او لكي يعني
يذهب مع
من سيتم اجلائهم من الرعايه الموجودين في
بورت سودان
نعم كثير من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه خاصه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبريطانيا
وعدد من الدول وصلوا بالفعل الى مدينه
بورسودان خلال الساعات الماضيه هنالك ايضا
عديد رعايه الدول ما زالوا بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لكن ايضا علمنا من بعض
المصادر بان الاجراءات لنقلهم من الخرطوم
ومن عدد من المدن السودانيه تستمر سواء
كان الاجلاء من الخرطوم او من شرق السودان
في هذه النقطه الحيويه التي نتحدث منها من
الميناء او من المطار
لكن تؤكد البعثات وتؤكد الهيئات
الدبلوماسيه بان عمليه التنسيق مستمره
عمليه الترتيب لنقل الرعايه مستمره هذه
العمليه تمضي نحن الان نتحدث عن اليوم
التاسع لعمليه الاجلاء عبر البحر هذه
العمليه بدات منذ الحادي والعشرين من شهر
ابريل الحالي عبر ميناء بورسودان وبدات
منذ الثالث والعشرين من هذا الشهر من داخل
مطار بورسودان الدولي مشاهد الجنود المشاه
البحريه الامريكيه والجيش البريطاني وعدد
من الوحدات العسكريه التي تتبع لمختلف دول
العالم اصبح مشهدا معتادا هنا في ميناء
بورسودان هذه القطعه البحريه تاتي بمرافقه
مع جنود مع قيادات مع ضباط يتبعون لدولهم
لتسهيل عمليات الاجراء والتسهيل عمليات
الوصول هذه القطعه كملخص اخير هذه القطعه
ستغادر بعد قليل مباشره الى ميناء جده
وبعدها مباشره هنالك ترتيبات ستتم داخل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه القطعه
الامريكيه طبعا
العمل الانساني مستمر منذ بدايه الازمه في
اخلاء الرعايه من الدول الشقيقه والصديقه
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه اليوم في
على سفينه جلاله الملك الدرعيه نقلنا 52
من الرعايه كان من ضمنهم من باكستان 15 من
نيبال 19 من السودان ومن عمان سته ومن
الجنسيه الامريكيه عدد واحد نقول لهم
الحمد لله على السلامه وان شاء الله ان
امورهم مرتبه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
ويسالون سالمين ان شاء الله الى اهاليهم
قالت رئيسه العمليات الميدانيه لليونيسف
في السودان جل لولر في بيان الله قالت ان
اليونيسف على درايه بان هناك اكثر من 15
مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
مؤكده ان الوضع الحالي الذي يشهده السودان
من قصف وهجمات هو في تزايد
اننا على درايه تامه بان قبل حدوث ازمه
السودان الحاليه هناك اكثر من خمسه عشر
مليون شخص بحاجه الى المساعدات الانسانيه
من بينهم ثمانيه ملايين طفل وان القصف
الجوي والهجمات على البنيه التحتيه للمياه
وتدمير اللقاحات الحيويه التي تشهدها
البلاد ستكون في ارتفاع ملحوظ
حذر المتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه في
السودان خالد عمر يوسف من انتشار
المواجهات الاثنيه والقوميه في البلاد في
ظل احتدام الاقتتال بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع واضاف يوسف ان استمرار الحرب التي
لن ينتصر فيها طرف كما انها ستفتح بابا
للمواجهات القوميه في كل البلاد ولن تصبح
هنالك دوله بالاساس
ومعنى من باريس الصحه والمحلل السياسي
السوداني محمد الاسباط مرحبا بك معي سيد
محمد في هذه النشره يعني السؤال اليوم عن
المشهد
السوداني عن هذه التحذيرات من انزلاق
الوضع الحالي عبد الله حمدو كان قد حذر
ايضا من الانزلاق الى ما يشبه النموذج
الليبي او السوري ايضا كذلك او اليمني
وقال بان السودان يعني سيكون نموذج اكبر
من هذه النماذج في الاقتتال وربما الحاله
الاهليه وقبل قليل ايضا هذه التحذيرات
تتزايد كذلك برايك كيف يمكن تقييم الوضع
الحالي هل يتجه الى هذا الاتجاه السيء
بوصفهم
مساء الخير مساء النور مع كل اسف يعني
كل الاحتمالات
احتمال ان تنزلق الحرب الى حرب اهليه
تنتقل الى مثلما حدث في الجنينه وهو نموذج
فارسي
اذا
حادث اذا اشتغلت الحرب الى اي مدينه اخرى
في الشمال وفي الشرق او في اليمين او في
الغرب
ستكون اكثر ماساويه واكثر فارسيه واكثر
دمرا مما هو حادث في الخرطوم خلال
الاسبوعين الماضي ايضا هنالك
القائدين الحرب العبثيه
جنرال البرهان
الحمر الاراده
ايقاف الحرب وان
يعني تتواصل الضغط
الاقليمي والدولي
عليهما
لايقاف القتال
المعطيات الاوليه تقول انه ربما تم تجديد
هذه الهدنه مره اخرى لثلاثه ايام او
لاسبوع
وربما ايضا بنفس الغدر خمسين في المئه
خمسين في الميه ان يستانف القطار ويكون
اكثر دراوه في
بدءا من يوم
المفارقه في المشهد السوداني ان في اي
مكان في العالم في حاله الحروب وفي حاله
الكوارث عندما يفشل تفشل الشرطه ولكن
يستدعى الجيش ولكن في السودان وهو حاله
سودانيه طبعا
عندما فشلت جيش بحسم الحرب استدعى الشرطه
وهذه لم تحدث اصلا في اي مكان في العالم
سوى في السودان انت تعني بان الجيش فشل في
السيطره على الوضع الحالي الجيش يقول يعني
من جانبه بانه قادر على هذه المعركه خلال
ايام لكنه يخشى من ان يصبح
مدنيون جزءا منها باستهدافهم في هذه
المعركه وهذه المواجهات مع قوات الدعم
السريع وهذا ما ابطا هذه العمليه حتى هذه
اللحظه سيد محمد
ويبغى للمعطيات في الميدان انا انا لا
اعتمد كثيرا على بيانات الجيش وبيانات
الدعم السريع لان بيانات بيانات كلا
الطرفين يعني تفتقر الى المصداقيه وعندما
يصدر احدهما بيان تكذبه الوقائع بعد ساعات
انا استند على المعطيات على الارض يعني
على مدى اسبوعين الان دخلنا في الاسبوع
الثالث لم تحسب المعرفه هذا يعني ان القوه
او الضعف الفريقين هي في حاله توازن
وبالتالي في مثل هذه الحالات لا يوجد يعني
لا توجد مؤشرات واضحه للحسد
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من باريس الصحفيه والمحل
السياسي السوداني محمد الاسباط شكرا جزيلا
لك
[موسيقى]
الان الى جوله على ابرز الاخبار الدوليه
حيث نشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه صورا لما
قالت انه استهداف لوحدات عسكريه جنوب
اوكرانيا وقالت الدفاع الروسيه انه تم
تنسيق القصف عبر صور مباشره تم التقاطها
بطائره مسيره
اكد رئيس الاوكراني على ان قوته جاهزه لشن
الهجوم المضاد رغما عدم استلام الطائرات
المقاتله من الغرب
بصراحه كانت الطائرات ستساعدنا كثيرا في
الهجوم المضاد لكننا نتفهم ايضا انه لا
يمكن ادراجها ضمن خططنا في الوقت الحالي
وهذا هو السبب في اننا سنبدا الامر قبل
استلام طائره اف 16 او انواع اخرى روسيا
مطمئنه لاعتقادها اننا ما زلنا بحاجه الى
شهرين لبدء الهجوم المضاد بعد التدريب على
الطائرات نقول هذا لا يحدث سنبدا الهجوم
ونمضي قدما لكن في الوقت نفسه هذا مهم
للغايه لاستلام الطائرات المقاتله الغربيه
في الاثناء كشفت شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
عن معلومات وفقا لصور التقطتها الاقمار
الصناعيه ان روسيا انشات خنادق دفاعيه
تمتد من القرم وحتى
تحسبا للهجوم الاوكراني المضاد مشيره الى
ان روسيا عمل طيله الاشهر السته الماضيه
على بناء مجموعه معقده من الدفاعات التي
يصعب اختراقها حيث تتركز خنادق روسيا بشكل
اكبر قرب الخطوط الاماميه في الشرق وتمتد
من زبولوجيا الى القرمه
مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه رائد كيف تبدو
الامور الميدانيه في دونيتسك حتى هذه
اللحظه
واستمرار المعارك الى اين وصل في باخم
التحديد
مساء الخير نايف يعني لابد من البدء من من
الترقب والحذر الشديدين اللذان تشهدهما
المنطقه من قبل القوات الانفصاليه هنا حيث
المقاطعات الانفصاليه وايضا من قبل الجيش
الروسي بعد اعلان القوات الاوكرانيه
والغرب بشكل عام عن عمليات او هجمات مضاده
على مناطق سيطره الجيش الروسي ربما تكون
هذه العمليات قد بدات تدريجيا حيث الايام
الماضيه التي شهدت قصفا شديدا لمدينه
دانيه يعني زخات من صواريخ فان بير تشيكيه
الصنع التي
خلفت اكثر من عشره ضحايا وعشرات الاصابات
ايضا طائرات مسيره استهدفت منطقه شبه
جزيره القرم في سيباسطو بالمستودعات
الوقود اصابت اهم المستودعات للوقود كما
ان فجر اليوم شهد مقتل خمسه مدني في
بريانس نحن نتحدث عن الاراضي داخل روسيا
نايف وليس في المناطق الانفصاليه خمسه
قتلى واعداد من الاصابات بالفعل الجيش
الروسي ولدينا معلومات من مصادر خاصه بانه
بالفعل كان يعمل على تحصين دفاعات خلال
الاشهر الماضيه ليست المخابرات البريطانيه
وحدها الذي تقول ذلك او الدفاع البريطانيه
بالفعل هذه معلومات اكيده بان الجيش
الروسي يعمل من اجل صد الهجوم الاوكراني
المرتقب في جميع المحاور ان كان في خرسون
او فيزا باروج لابد من الاشاره ان المناطق
الجنوبيه حيث خرسون وزاباروجي حيث
المنشا النوويه في زبروج تقع هذه المنشاه
على الضفه الجنوبيه من نهرديني برو حيث
سحب الجيش الروسي الى الضفه الشماليه وهو
يعني تعتبر هذه المنشاه اقرب الى الجانب
الاوكراني وتع السلطات الانفصاليه هناك
بان هناك حشودات اوكرانيه كبيره وربما
يعود الجيش الاوكراني لمحاوله السيطره على
هذه المحطه النوويه ايضا يعني معارك
مستعره ومستمره في المحور الشرقي هنا في
مقاطعه واهمها كالعاده مدينه باخموت
فاقنر قال بان قواته تسيطر على ما نسبه
90% من جغرافيه مدينه باخمه لكن المنطقه
الغربيه التي يتمركز فيها الجيش الاوكراني
ما زال يقاتل الجيش الاوكراني ببساله
وايضا كما اسلفت اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه
انها تحافظ على الطريق السريع من مدينه
شاسوفيار الذي يمد المقاتلين المتمركزين
داخل المدينه في الناحيه الغربيه الحديث
عن اكثر من 15 الف مقاتل اوكراني
قوات فاغنر والجيش الروسي يحاولون اكمال
من بلده بغداد من الناحيه الشماليه
الغربيه ومن ايفان افكاء الجنوبيه الغربيه
لو استطاعوا فعلا من دخول او اقتحام هذا
ثاني البلدان ربما يكون يعني باستطاعتهم
قطع الامدادات وحصار المقاتلين الاوكرانيه
شكرا نفسه اكد انه اتفق مع الجيش الروسي
على عدم التعجل بالسيطره على كامل المدينه
ذلك الاستنزاف القوات الاوكرانيه وقتل
اكثر من خمس
مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل
قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي انه واثق من
امكانيه التوصل الى اتفاق بشان خطه
الاصلاح القضائي المثيره للجدل التي
طرحتها حكومته مؤكدا على ان ادارته تعمل
على حل هذا الجدل من خلال المفاوضات
هناك نقاش اساسي بيننا بشان الاصلاح
القضائي لكننا نبذل جهدا لحل هذا الجدل من
خلال المفاوضات اعتقد انه بفضل النوايا
الحسنه للطرفين فانني على ثقه من امكانيه
التوصل الى الاتفاق وانا اؤيد ذلك تماما
ملايينه البريطانيين سيحضرون للمره الاولى
في التاريخ تتويج ملك بريطانيا فقد اعلن
مكتب اساقفه كنتربري ان تتويج الملك
تشارلز يوم السبت سيتم امام ملايين الناس
كما جرت تقاليد التتويج التاريخيا وسيكون
الولاء للملك جمهوريا بدلا عن الاكتفاء
بولاء الاقران الورثه
اعلن رجل الاعمال الملياردير ايلون ماسك
عن خطه لمنصه تويتر التي يملكها تسمح لنشر
الوسائل الاعلاميه بتقاضي بدل من
المستخدمين على اساس قراءه كل مقاله على
حدب وبنقره واحده وقال ماسك ان الخطه
ستمكن المستخدمين الذين لم يشتركوا شهريا
بدفع بدل اعلى مقابل قراءه كل مقاله بشكل
عابر وان الامر سيشكل مكسبا رئيسيا
للمؤسسات الاعلاميه والجمهور
هذه الساعه الاخباريه التي ناقشنا
وتناولنا الملف السوداني في معظمها
التغطيه مستمره على راس الساعه مع الزميل
طالب كنعان اليك يا طالب لمتابعه المزيد
من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات